let's go next to kevin from san diego
kevin welcome
hey david how's it going it's going well
i was not expecting to call me i was
like busy with playing video games all
right well um yeah so
um i guess i'm still
i'm still wondering like what is uh what
is gonna happen with this this trump
execution of a search warrant because it
was not actually a raid um
is uh
have we have we found anything more out
about uh what's going on with that
in what sense find out more and what do
you mean like is are there going to be
charges that type of thing well i mean
the latest thing that i heard was that
there was um trump was looking after
getting the uh what was it the affidavit
yeah
it released to everyone um which i think
pat was saying on like monday or
something you know that could backfire
on on trump if
that's something but we don't really
know what's in that affidavit yet
um yeah i don't know i'm just
i'm wondering
how how all of that's gonna how uh
that's gonna shake out if uh
listen we don't know yet there's a
couple different things that might
happen if it sort of evaporates and
nothing happens and there's no charges
and it just kind of fades the narrative
from the right will be this was
unnecessary and outrageous and meant to
humiliate trump and they will have a
case that that case will feel very
strong if that's the case because this
is a big step to take it was a
completely legal step
they crossed all the eyes and dotted all
the t's as sean hannity said um
but
it if nothing happens to do this to a
president is a big step so that's one
possibility and that will probably
strengthen the right beyond that there's
a number of other possible scenarios
whose timing you know is it before after
the midterms is it before after trump
potentially declares his candidacy for
24 there's just too many unknowns right
now to say
yeah i mean i am really i i want it to
be something where i see having like the
affidavit get released but like redacted
any kind of people's names that uh
would be
uh
potentially targets of right-wing
extreme people going after them uh that
i think that would be good because
having something that like sort of
proves like yeah trump does have
somebody that's in his organization that
basically sold him out and told them
that there was uh there was all these
documents that would be i think the
potentially most damaging thing that
could come from the affidavit which is
the confirmation that there is a sort of
mole or traitor which has been
speculated but not proven
yeah but then again that also comes with
the the downside of
if the mole or traitor is revealed but
it's not redacted then like that
person's going to be everybody's going
to go be going after them like
them going after bruce wayne and the
dark knight returns which i don't want i
want people to be safe so yeah yeah that
would be bad uh well let's give it
another couple weeks and see where we
are you know around mid-september
yeah sounds right all right thank you
for the call very much appreciated we're
gonna take the quickest of breaks but
don't hang up because then we're going
right back to the discord lines and
we're going to hear from more people so
just stand by we will be right back with
more of your calls
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at
blinkist.com david pakman the link is
down below